hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play Oh God
ha ha welcome to a brand new let's play
of cry of fear memories I'm not actually
gonna go through a couple of these
subscriber campaigns because I really
like I really like crime fear and
they're making some good ones and the
one I'm gonna play which is memories was
actually made by the team who made the
original cry fear and the community
together so I want to give that one a
try so here we go
immediately Leigh DMZ flew served me
pretty well I think I've done all the
cry fear games on medium and I end up
dying a lot anyway so
like most things I have no idea what's
going on
[Music]
okay
okie-dokie
emboldened to tell one I like almost
everything that I played so far has been
from Sweden hey it's Simon
okey-dokey
Simon Uncle Phil this by itself won't
make you feel better
[Music]
past manic past Nanak okay I didn't
think we were gonna be playing Simon
again but it's cool I like Simon I mean
he's a fucked-up little kid but I'm
sorry fudged up
he's a fudged up little kid and unlike
that oh yeah I'm back in Sweden I'm good
to talk in Sweden talk all Hugh
Americans sorry if you can't understand
me my sweetest followers will understand
me
no [ __ ] far series hmm interesting
very now [ __ ] you I could wear I won't
you fill now this looks diable it's a
lens flare Hey
or you will say no you're short
to get the right way
no thingies leave okay I should probably
listen to him yeah okay so I'm actually
going to leave
okay don't curse
to get there great we owe nothing is
left
I can't turn left I'm not an ambit
earner
or what to the left
okay
No stop getting in front of my audience
ma why
[Music]
Wow I like this oh I like the deformable
environments you fool
I'll get my foot lost somewhere in you
Oh out of it
okey-dokey
what there what do you see
Oh
oh my god
oh man I was terrible
[Music]
that is not right come on
you mean kill you allegedly I hate you
to you
yep
sounds good to me that's my victory yeah
that's my sweetie speaks to read it okay
all right I just gave the people on
tumblr another thing to put me as a gift
a gift a gift if you have it if you
haven't visited my tumblr page um I've
got a fan run tumblr page I don't run it
myself but some great people from the
community to do and I'm really
appreciative that they do that so here's
more turn that into a gif link I guess
so I memo but all right oh yeah
Debbie's dead okay I'm gonna keep track
of my time
and slow Oh can't hit me what's this
ha ha oh that hurt ah do it hey where'd
you come from
you supposed to be slow ah [ __ ] you
they're hitting each other God these
things are freaking that look guy it
looks like this sweater that pretty how
ha ha ha each other come on man I need a
gun Wow
[ __ ] hell he's gonna kill me no he's
not no he's not ha ha I am the winner
[Music]
why didn't I get the shotgun earlier cuz
I'm in murder
run oh I love me shout gun the where'd
that come from and what was that and oh
sorry and Wow
[Music]
oh it's the tree of Tim hey I see easier
oh come on I'm not gonna waste a full
another a whole nother shell on them oh
yeah yeah good sympathy one's a piece of
me hmm
oh I can I can punch with my face it's
about as effective as a switchblade
forgot the controls are evicted wakey
this will lead to Trekkie if they
actually have to gain out that's a very
oh oh there we go ah I'm a 3ds ninja
this is like what is that a pieces green
tada - ciao boo boo boo boo ah - wrong
area lady
Chapter three
where is Chapter two did I miss chapter
two take it did acceptors are going by
very quickly very quickly
I hope this this custom story is a
little long we are enough with that so
here I have this custom stories a little
longer than the last one as I was kind
of disappointed but of course nothing
makes sense in this one so I shouldn't
anticipate I got a gnat flying on me
yeah here ah come on I shoot you here we
go
and in our hips down completely missing
is my strategy
that's how I that's how I roll oh what
the hell was that
no I reloaded that is that same plug
needs to finish the reload cycle before
I switch back or else it won't count it
don't know what that was
Oh Oh his place is just fudged uh what
is that
oh ah that's a lovely that's usually the
face it disappears really quickly
hi there oh they're given me a lot of
guns I'm gonna run out of space too I'm
gonna run out of space oh god oh this is
afraid of monsters stuff oh I see
they're all you're gonna fraid of Oscars
guy ah [ __ ] hit on no I just oh [ __ ] I
just lost all that hello oh oh oh ah
yeah here what the [ __ ] you got a knife
there you go John - to Guam okay yeah
this is like oh hello yeah that's tuffly
that's an afraid of monsters monster all
right screw it I'm not I'm not wasting
ammo on the beds cuz I know I can just
get by them
okay where will this store take me away
from here I'm pretty sure that's where
it's gonna take me this NAT is hanging
around my pop-filter don't know one
chapter for her oh pretty ah
anyway I'm out of time for this episode
so thank you all so much for watching
hope you're enjoying this campaign I am
utterly confused but then again it told
me that I should be so thanks again for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye
[Music]